a plena luz del día el ejército israelí
volvió a protagonizar en jenning una
mortífera redada con varias víctimas
mortales palestinas y múltiples heridos
numerosas unidades de las fuerzas
israelíes con autos blindados
francotiradores y hasta un helicóptero
entraron en el campo de refugiados sobre
las 3 de la tarde para llevar a cabo
arrestos en concreto en una vivienda que
rodearon y sobre la que también lanzaron
un proyectil según el Primer Ministro
israelí Benjamin netanyahu entre los
fallecidos en la incursión estaba el
atacante palestino que el 26 de febrero
mató a dos israelíes en jugará por su
parte la media luna roja Palestina
denunció una vez más que militares
israelíes impidieron el paso de
ambulancias para asistir a los heridos
mientras que la autoridad Palestina
responsabilizó al gobierno israelí por
aumentar una peligrosa escalada que
amenaza con hacer estallar esta
situación esta redada ha ocurrido en
paralelo a otra operación en la blues
que ha concluido con el arresto de tres
personas entre ellas
hijos del supuesto atacante de jugara
siempre de acuerdo a la prensa israelí
justo jugar ha sido centro de las
tensiones desde que el 26 de febrero
cientos de colonos israelíes atacaran
con violencia la aldea causando un
muerto y graves destrozos de viviendas y
autos en unos hechos que han sido
repudiados por la comunidad
internacional y que en menor escala
siguen sucediendo así la violencia sólo
van a aumento en cisjordania ocupada que
ya cuenta más de 70 palestinos muertos
por fuego israelí y del lado israelí 14
personas han fallecido en ataques
palestinos en Jerusalén este Isis
Jordania ocupada